bonsoir et bienvenue pour l'actualité
locale sur tv fil 78 en ce 9 mars 2015
il sera notamment question de la course
au soleil qui a débuté dimanche depuis
les yvelines le paris-nice s'est élancé
de maurepas pour un prologue qui a tenu
toutes ses promesses et à l'occasion du
passage du paris nice dans le
département une centaine d'élèves de la
section sportive du collège hélène
boucher à voisins-le-bretonneux
rencontré ce matin trois anciens
coureurs cyclistes et alors que vient de
se refermer le mondial du tatouage à
paris rencontre avec christophe il
pratique son art depuis deux ans et
vient de s'installer à coignières il
existe aujourd'hui en france plus de
4000 boutique l'annoncé de la fermeture
de l'école camille claudel à plaisir qui
inquiète les parents d'élèves une partie
d'entre mobilisés ce week-end face à la
mairie je sais film coleman ce berger et
son adjointe à l'éducation était
présente des échanges tendus alors que
la municipalité envisage de répartir les
quarante quatre écoliers inscrits cette
année dans deux autres établissements de
la ville pour les parents d'élèves cela
signifie tout simplement des classes
surchargées à venir l'école
camille-claudel depuis plusieurs années
maintenant sert quand même de soupape on
va dire aux autres écoles c'est à dire
que quand on arrive à un chiffre assez
élevé d'effectifs dans les autres écoles
les enfants viennent ici sont balthus
basculer ici donc parce que ce qu'on
sait c'est que leur bon pour l'instant
mois de mars les effectifs sont prévus
un certain chiffre
ils vont encore évoluer d'ici le mois de
juin et même en septembre donc si on
septembre les classes sont pleines à
jacques prévert et à gérard philipe les
autres enfants l'aimé où on est mais
camille claudel pour l'instant mais si
l'école ferme
il y aura plus de soupapes et les
enfants ils vont aller où ils vont
continuer de les faire grimper les
chiffres dans les classes et rien n'est
encore arrêté
la discussion se poursuit avec
l'éducation nationale le paris nice à
présent qui s'est donc ouvert dimanche
dans les yvelines avec un prologue de
6 7 km à maurepas au-delà de l'aspect
festif on retiendra côté sportif la
victoire du champion du monde le
polonais michal kraft au ski côté
français sylvain chavanel septième et à
10 secondes de quoi ravir les
spectateurs qui ont découvert la
richesse du plateau de 7 3 73e édition
de la course au soleil
c'est une belle course un beau parcours
exigeant qui demande de la dextérité est
bon on tombe sur un coureur qui est très
adroit parce que je crois que si mes
souvenirs sont bons il doit venir un
petit peu du cyclo cross ou du vdt et
sur un parcours comme ça ça aide
énormément et les jeunes donc il a
vraiment la volonté d'aller chercher une
belle victoire et je pense qu'il faudra
aller le chercher et nous allons
continuer à parler de cyclisme sport
avec nos invités qui viennent
s'installer en plateau philippe plumas
bonsoir soir venez vous installer
également et christophe beaux visages
professeurs et deux ps dans l
établissement scolaire hélène boucher un
voisin le bretonneux et philippe
l'humain vous en être le principal de
cet établissement une centaine d'élèves
de la section sportive de ce collège qui
a rencontré ce matin trois anciens
coureurs à l'occasion donc du passage du
paris nice dans le département nous
regardons pour débuter ce reportage
réalisé ce matin par mélanie poker ils
ont en face d'eux trois anciens
champions cyclistes
mais pour une question de générations
ces collégiens ou du travail et la
rencontre le prof nous a dit de nous
renseigner sur internet donc un
joaillier à peu près qui s'était ces 100
élèves du collège hélène boucher sont
tous en section sport et ce matin est
interviewé bernard hinault quintuple
vainqueur du tour de france gilbert
duclos-lassalle de paris roubaix au
palmarès et sandy casar vainqueur de
trois étapes sur la grande boucle
partager notre expérience avec eux leurs
10 ans bac il faut se battre il faut
rien n'est facile que le génie 1
je leur ai dit vous faut pas croire que
tout arrive comme ça c'est la vie c'est
une compétition donc
il faut y aller faut y aller faut bien
travailler à l'école et si on a cette
chance de faire du sport il faut aussi
bien travaillé pour être le meilleur et
le meilleur c'est aussi bien dans temps
à l'école
souvent je me disais que j'étais pas le
seul une heure de questions réponses
préparées deux semaines auparavant avec
leurs professeurs autour de la carrière
des souvenirs des champions mais aussi
de l'argent et du dopage
une heure de rencontre peut-être un peu
trop courte pour certains d'entre eux
c'était super intéressant mais cette
machine sont pas restés plus longtemps
on aurait pu poser encore d'autres
questions et puisse avoir encore
d'autres choses même si un jeu et
reviennent et pas de problème power pour
imposer d'autres indications
les champions sont partis rejoindre la
ligne de départ de la première étape de
paris nice pour les élèves direction les
cours avec une belle photo souvenir
nous parlons donc de cette rencontre a à
présent avec le principal de
l'établissement est l'un des enseignants
deux ps également comment ça s'est mis
en place tout simplement ce ses murs
place l'initiative du conseil général
qui nous a demandés sont accepté
d'accueillir trois coureurs trois
champions à trois avec ce contrat
champions et on a mis ça en place avec
le conseil général et les professeurs
d'éducation physique et sportive mère
justement qu'elle est un peu l'objectif
c'était pas uniquement une rencontre
autour du sport ce matin nous étions
fiers effectivement de saisir une
opportunité de
de faire en sorte que nos élèves croiser
ces trois ex champion ça s'est mis en
place effectivement rapidement
simplement mais grâce au travail de mes
collègues profs de français grâce au
travail de ma collègue de d'arts
plastiques qui a su faire de cette
action quelque chose de sympathique pour
l'ensemble des élèves de l'établissement
donc c'est enrichissant plusieurs
niveaux en fait on leur montre non
seulement les disciplines sportives et
que les témoignages des champions mais
c'est aussi pour l'éducation au sens
large disons qu'on a permis à nos élèves
d'aller vers une culture sportive un
petit peu plus approfondie et on aura on
leur a permis effectivement de vivre une
expérience hors du commun s'adressait à
des champions c'est pas c'est pas si
évident que ça prendre la parole devant
150 personnes même si c'est des
camarades dans une dans une ambiance un
peu particulière avec votre présence et
les filles c'est des situations
inhabituelles pour les élèves et surtout
le fait d'avoir par anticipation
programmer les questions les la manière
de les formuler
c'est enrichissant aussi ce qu'ils
veulent c'est en agissant pour les pour
les élèves dans leur façon de travailler
c'est quelque chose qui ait conduit
fréquemment dans l'établissement vous
essayez de changer un petit peu on pas
les méthodes pédagogiques mais en tout
cas les approche un peu différente
c'est de faire voler de pédagogie
recevoir trois champions c'est
extrêmement rare mais selon des
approches pédagogiques ont trait sur la
transversalité
on a un coach qui a beaucoup de projets
des projets sportifs et des projets
culturels tas de choses qui sont fausses
à l'établissement pour les faire évoluer
pour apporter une richesse la différence
apporte la richesse bien sûr justement
par rapport au projet sportif
l'établissement a une vocation un petit
peu encourager les talents sportifs
oui oui mais des moyens beaucoup de
moyens on soutient évidemment les moyens
un il ya qu une section sportive qu'il
faut sont extrêmement bien
il ya quand même une section badminton
qui fonctionne aux élèves ont été vice
champion de france de baten quelque
chose qui fonctionne bien une mousse
mousse qui se passe bien une émulation
qui se passe très bien et en même temps
ça permet aux autres autres élèves de la
place qu on mixe les classes d'avoir 100
toute une faune une bonne émulation pour
pouvoir travailler et réussir l'objectif
étant toujours la réussite de nos élèves
bien évidemment c'est quoi c'est créer
un esprit de compétition aussi entre les
élèves
non plutôt une bonne ambiance de travail
une envie de s'entraider pour pour
justement avancer ensemble les classes
qui était ce matin
face aux trois champions malheureusement
on n'a pas pu mettre tout
l'établissement devant devant ses trois
champions
les quatre classes qui était représentée
est concerné par cette conférence sont
des classes à profil sportives ne sont
pas là que pour la pratique sportive
bien évidemment ils sont là pour
apprendre à travailler ensemble dans un
esprit différent d'une classe entre
guillemets lambda le badminton leur
petite spécialité est là pour essayer au
contraire de créer de l'unité et de
faire en sorte que les classes à avance
dans un bon esprit de camaraderie et
d'entraidé
ce qui est important aussi parce qu'on
revient sur le seul événement de ce
matin sur les témoignages qui ont été
apportées c'est de montrer aussi que
l'investissement sportif
là c'est pas forcément synonyme de
gloire de richesse de fortune parce que
quelquefois ça peut séduire aussi les
plus jeunes pour s'inscrire dans ces
filières là et tout le monde ne vient
pas bernard hinault a terminé ce matin
cette conférence justement par ces mots
là savoir que je me souviens qu'il a pu
dire à nos élèves c'est si tu veux être
un champion pour gagner de l'argent tu
gagneras pas de course par contre si tu
as envie de gagner des courses tu
gagneras effectivement peut-être un peu
d'argent donc j'ai trouvé vraiment le
formule intéressante et justement autour
du cyclisme aussi ça va se poursuivre
vous me disais juste avant de débuter le
journal ils vont encore avoir une
rencontre autour du vélodrome territoire
du vélo savoir qu'on a programmé c'est
un peu le fait du hasard et on a
programmé effectivement une visite du
vélodrome et une participation d'une
partie de ses élèves sur les activités
de piste sur enfin de vélo sur piste et
de et de bmx oui on va on va continuer
un petit peu laventure vélo sachant que
dès l'es2 les deux projets n'étaient pas
vraiment ne sont pas liés mais
l'actualité autour du vélo à saint
quentin en yvelines est assez en ce
moment forcément entre les mondiaux qui
sont terminées puis le paris-nice de ce
week-end dès le départ ce matin de la
première étape du département des
yvelines également une toute dernière
question vous évoquiez tout à l'heure le
les nombreux projets de l'établissement
soient sportives culturelles mais
quelques-uns qu'on peut qu'on peut
aborder lequel sera le plus grand projet
à venir plus grand projet celui qui va
vous occuper d'ici aux vacances
oui bon les vacances ils vont aller en
angleterre nous et là forcément l'avis
d'un collège au quotidien merci à tous
les deux d'être venu en plateau pour
nous parler de cette rencontre de ce
matin et puis de la politique menée
autour du sport dans votre établissement
le collège
hélène boucher tout autre sujet à
présent le tatouage qui s'est
aujourd'hui démocratiser il existerait
plus de 4000 boutique contre une
quarantaine dans les années 80 au total
1 français sur 10 qui déclarent s'être
fait tatouer rencontre au lendemain du
mondial du tatouage à paris avec
christophe il est installé à coignières
où il pratique son art yolaine thorez
elodie - c'est la dernière étape avant
de passer aux traits indélébile et
définitif
christophe propose toujours à ses
clients un aperçu au carbone pour
valider une dernière fois le motif du
tatouage et l'emplacement
ensuite il ne reste plus qu'à prendre
son mal en patience
il va tranquillement le pouce et tracer
des traits et puis de faire le fer le
motif mais voilà il n'y a pas de
précipitation et puis 1 1 déjà pour la
netteté des traits je dirais christophe
s'est installé ici à coignières il ya
près de trois mois et depuis son salon
fonctionne surtout grâce au bouche à
oreille à la base de passionné de dessin
et de peinture il s'est mis au tatouage
il y a deux ans
les premiers tatouage c'est et on va
dire sur moi et puis très vite après ça
a été long à dire sur les copains sur la
famille sur comment dire des collègues
je veux dire avant même de de faire des
clients sa marque de fabrique l'écoutent
et la réflexion avec ses clients ils
passent parfois plusieurs heures a créé
le motif qui collent à leurs envies ils
l'affirment ce n'est pas le débit qui
l'intéressent mais la qualité
alors il prend son temps il propose
toujours un premier rendez-vous de
contact j'essaye de savoir
éventuellement au plus près ce qui ce
qu'ils recherchent je veux dire dans son
tatouage
ça permet de faire du sur mesure et de
personnaliser jeudi au delà du tatouage
qui doivent flash qu'on appelle c'est à
dire que pour passer à quelque chose
simplement un copier coller ça a été une
vraie concertation c'est christophe
c'est à dire que voilà on s'est vus
avant on a choisi on a revu les choses
sont en confiance avec le mec quand même
qui va te tuer c'est hyper important
la méthode semble fonctionner les
clients se fidélise après la
cicatrisation d'ici trois semaines janyk
reviendra pour les derniers détails et
avec quelques idées derrière la tête
peut en faire un quatrième voire un
cinquième
un dernier mot pour terminer ce journal
nous en parlions la semaine dernière
visiblement malgré l'interdiction
formelle certains aiment prendre des
risques un couple propriétaire d'un
drone a été placé en garde à vue ce
dimanche 8 mars dans la soirée à l'hôtel
de police de versailles l'homme et la
femme tous deux âgés de 48 ans sont
accusés d'avoir survolé château avec un
engin équipé d'une caméra avec retour
vidéo sur la télécommande et tout cela
sans autorisation ils risquent 75000
euros d'amendé
un an de prison le journal revient
demain mardi aux mêmes horaires les
précédentes éditions l'intégralité
également des reportages disponible en
replay sur notre site internet
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez également
nous suivre sur les réseaux sociaux
excellente soirée